it's the end of the world man oh my
goodness end of the world is upon us
and the signs are here my grandma's been
telling me this for years actually as
she really I'm dead serious been telling
me for years what is what is she saying
it's the end of the world it's coming
soon
whenever why does she think so we're
just random stuff like anything that's
going on in the world like how times I
mean it I don't know how we get into
these conversations but she always slips
it in there that it's like well I'm not
even worried cuz it's thin anyway I'm
imagine I know where I'm going I'm
imagining it's like you're you're
sitting down and she's like Adam I need
to talk to you about something serious
and then it's like I mentioned a time
lapse and she's like oh yeah and like
you Trump apocalypse yeah yeah beanie
babies apocalypse just like yeah yeah
Papa John's got fired
apocalypse alright grandma so this is
actually a story from a few weeks ago we
are in the last days locust swarm
approaching Egypt sparks bit Bible
apocalypse fears a locust swarm
approaching Egypt has led a Bible
scholar to claim we are in the last days
urging Christians to prepare for the
second coming of Christ now apparently
this story is actually only gotten worse
China has moved in we did talk about a
little bit but the reason I bring this
up is because that's the big news is
actually this Russia earthquake now this
is from today 7.5 7.5 and it sent a
tsunami warning through I think Hawaii
at the warning to an earth quake which
struck near Russia's coral islands has
led the Pacific Tsunami Warning Center
to warn of possible hazardous tsunami
waves within 620 miles check this out so
I think it does it did they gave a
warning to Hawaii you can see I think
you know Japan probably got it as well
yeah
tsunami warnings have been issued after
a huge 7.5 magnitude earthquake struck
off the coast of a Russian island the US
Geological Survey said Wednesday
Wednesday's quake struck 135 miles
southeast of Russia's coral islands
chain at north of Japan the Pacific
Tsunami Warning Center said hazardous
tsunami waves were possible within 620
miles
it added earthquakes of this strength in
the past have caused tsunamis far from
the epicenter
and the US National tsunami warning
center was analyzing the event to
determine the level of danger
however meteorological officials in
Japan issued no alerts following the
quake although they said there might be
slight tidal changes now I always have
to rain on everyone's parade oh yeah cuz
right now I'm gonna do it so well
there's gonna be a ton of people and
they're gonna back oh man I'm so
interested like what are these things
happening well if you'd like to hear
about crazy shenanigans turn on History
Channel for ancient aliens here we're a
bit more skeptical earthquakes and
tsunamis happen yeah they have been all
the time and no one pays attention to
them but now that we're in the midst of
a national emergency
everything is standing out to everybody
yes so they're like locusts and like
earthquakes here and there and it's like
yeah but like here we go yeah there's
been a plague of not magpies there's a
certain type of bird that's taking over
Africa really yeah in like South Africa
not the country but like south of
southern right and it's they're just
they move to where the water is yeah
they always know so they're the first
ones there they eat up all the green
right away and they're just they're just
taking over yeah so it's pretty crazy
this one's funny expressed at that code
at UK is is very bullish on the
apocalypse the biblical one cuz they've
got a bunch of stories about this this
one is from March 17th coronavirus in
the Bible
preacher warns of apocalyptic signs as
end of world nears what do you mean the
coronavirus is in the bible lay the
facts upon me they say the crown of ours
has already killed more than 7,500
people it's actually way higher than
that now but a bigger disaster could be
brewing on the horizon
Indiana based preacher and evangelist
Paul Begley believes the coronavirus is
a sign of the end times Begley who
preaches from West Lafayette in the u.s.
spoke during an online sermon about the
prophetic meaning of coronavirus in a
broadcast titled prophetic prophetic
apocalyptic plagues of the end times he
said it passages from the Bible that
supposedly back his bizarre claims he
said the coronavirus has hit the world
and no one saw it coming or at least
very few did and what's happened is out
of Wuhan China the coronavirus has
exploded on the scene
the numbers of people infected way up in
the thousands and the death toll rising
everyday by the hundreds and yet there's
no cure no vaccines and really no one
can pinpoint the origin of this endtime
plague okay he just called it an endtime
plague he hasn't he hasn't given us any
reason like why he thinks that yeah I'm
still waiting for it and while the
bodies are piling up and people are
afraid the question becomes how to
prevent it and where will it spread next
as of 5:25 GMT and March 17th the in
fact you want to say yeah okay anyway
let's mean we already know this yeah
more than 190,000 people have been
affected okay so so here's here we go
here we go he says the bible does talk
about plagues in the last days he then
cited Christian scripture from Matthew
24 the passage in the Bible reads jesus
answered watch out that no one deceives
you for many will come come in my name
claiming I am the Messiah and will
deceive many and what is that if do
anything you will hear okay you will
hear of wars and rumors of wars but seed
see to it that you are not alarmed such
things must happen but the end is still
to come
nation will rise against nation and
Kingdom against Kingdom there will be
famines and earthquakes in various
places oh man having grace how
convenient all these are the beginning
of birth pains
according to pastor Begley these warning
signs of the end times are already
unfolding before our very own eyes there
is however nothing to suggest the
coronavirus is a is big enough or deadly
enough to be considered a biblical
plague okay no no wait a minute no there
wasn't he said that if the Bible refers
to the coronavirus and they never even
said it that was wait a second
yeah this articles from what last week I
don't know I didn't see yeah yeah yeah
let's go check the date on this
what is it March 17th I'm pretty sure
right updated March 17th okay and what
did he say earthquakes blah blah blah
there will be famines and earthquakes
and what are we seeing locusts are
ravaging crops mm-hmm locusts are a
biblical plague yeah and an earthquake
just hit you know to be honest if this
if you're looking for the signs you can
find them exact be real you know I mean
you find what you're looking for when or
they just said you know locusts kind of
go crazy and I think it's happened
before it's happened in the same areas
to where it's happening now
right so people ignore it exactly so he
says what is it the who said wait the
who said wait is therefore quite normal
for people to worry about the Cova 19
outbreak well how it will affect them
their loved ones
regardless pastor Begley said the
plagues of the last days or the plagues
of the end times they start the clock
ticking yes right the end is nigh and so
once you know of course there's another
story because I swear Express loves this
prophecy bizarre claim 4 Horsemen of the
Apocalypse have arrived wasn't someone
in the super chat just talking about
this you guys were saying like yeah it's
the horsemen coronavirus is infected a
lot of people is that this is from
earlier this month why are people
claiming the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse have arrived death so I'm
assuming that might be one that they're
referring to famine play yeah or no
pestilence
yeah war was at war famine pestilence I
don't know I don't know maybe I'll tell
us everyone's gonna go nuts in the
comments being like this is you know
that we can tell you yeah the world's in
the grips of the corona virus we get it
tell us about the horsemen I get it look
they just expressed stuffs the article
and then someone said here we go
militant Christians and Biblical
hardliners have flooded social media
with claims the corona virus is the
harbinger of the Apocalypse
John angel back tweeted coronavirus
hurricane katrina you ain't seen nothing
yet pal no Mike just read the book of
Revelation repent or your sin for your
sins before it is repent of your sins
before it is too late oh yes here's a
nice photo of what appears to be the
four horsemen you know taking people out
I do care about you and those who think
like you do and those who don't another
twitter twitter you said beginning of
Sorrows Matthew 24 3 through 8
Australian wildfires coronavirus
earthquakes and odd places increased
rage and murders worldwide massive
hunger increases and there are those
that laugh about the book of Revelation
but where are these outrageous claims
about Biblical prophecy coming from many
Christians believe the end of the world
was prophesized in the in the last
chapter of the Bible the book of
Revelation the book of Revelation
details the cataclysmic
that will unfold before the second
coming of Christ one of these events
will be the arrival of the Four Horsemen
apocalypse one of which is believed to
be represented by the coronavirus hmm
here we go death war famine pest and
pestilence or plague right evangelist
Gerald flurry and Wayne turjun of the
trumpet said we have already examined
the first three horsemen the first is
religious deception next is war than
famine wait which one is religious death
is with the fourth pestilence these
horsemen represent the final endtime
culmination of the most traumatic
problems endured by a rebellious mankind
they picture one of the most ominous
scenarios ever it is imperative that
each of us takes heed while there is
still time conspiracy theorists have
claimed online the coronavirus
represents the pale horse and it's rider
charity macabre tweeted the the writer
of this pale horse has been released on
earth today we can already see the
plagues of locusts and pestilence like
coronavirus that have brought death
locusts have brought famine John the
Apostle wrote in revelation 6 and I
looked and I behold a pale horse and his
name that sat on him was death and hell
followed with him I'm sorry I don't
understand how the corner of eyes is a
horse and I also I also love to point
out that Express just I got a bunch of
tweets from random Twitter users and
then claimed like there's some authority
here claiming this stuff is true I just
slapped it together is already really
confusing I think a lot of Christians
don't even understand it and there's
literally a verse in the Bible that says
not even Jesus knows when this is gonna
happen so there's no one who can
possibly say with any kind of assurance
or or apocalypse is now yeah and the
horseman is here to kill us all so
that's probably it look to be it's the
waiting I can't stand I don't they keep
running these stories express like they
must be getting a lot of clicks on these
I'm sure well well I think it's fun to
point out well look at the number one
videos you know trending on the
Nostradamus like I don't know look at
the Naboo Mar that's like outbreak
contagion right all these but you guys
thinks of course it is they want to talk
about loca
and stuff there's actually been two very
very terrifying signs that to me say the
apocalypse is coming oh yeah go on yeah
you thought you thought coronaviruses
scary the first is that Cheesecake
Factory will not be able to pay its rent
yes the end is here the time the end of
time he's cake factory where will I get
my cookie dough cheesecake after this as
far as I'm concerned I'm my world is
coming to an end they don't they don't
have a vegan cheese cake so no no no we
went there and they were mean to us
that's true it was one local chain they
were mean to us we walked out I'm not
gonna hold it against every Cheesecake
Factory but I must digress I was just
kidding obviously I don't care that much
about the Cheesecake Factory
but there are real signs of the end time
upon us like this one BuzzFeed is
slashing employee pay amid the crowd a
virus crisis amid my world is ending
where will I get my listicles and learn
about oh I don't know Billy Eilish for
the kids listen to these days this is
actually funny funny enough this is the
first time I've seen a bus oh this isn't
BuzzFeed no okay I was gonna say first
BuzzFeed article I've ever seen okay
well then I can still say I haven't seen
best you so so let me just let me just
wrap things up for everybody you know
it's fun to talk about the apocalypse
and revelations and maybe we should
actually do like a deep dive into like
theories and ideas like you know the
precession of the equinoxes kind of
stuff and what could revelations mean
for now we have all these articles
popping up where people cherry-pick
things and claim it's an analogous to
some prophecy yeah like they said there
would be a pair of pale horse what they
really meant was a tiny virus pale
microbe yes it turns up light on the
microscope I'm sorry man I don't know I
don't not see how you connect those two
things if a dude wrote it on a horse
like coughing and gagging and that's
what started everything I'd be like at
least thing I was on a horse where the
horse was coughing and gagging one of
the two I mean could you actually
imagine if like all of this started with
a dude riding a horse
wait that's not like considered a horse
like the Chinese a bet is a horse that
proves it that's it there you go exactly
Anaya
well you know I'm glad that we ended
this on a light note so you started on a
very very dark know where we actually
were like you know it's funny you want
to talk about the end of the world you
know got to talk about Bible's
prophecies in Nostradamus you talk about
hospitals deciding they're gonna DNR
people oh man that's that's scary that's
way scarier yeah that is pretty first
now I'll be I'll be honest if I saw four
dudes on horseback flying through the
sky I'd freak out yep okay but that's
just not gonna happen so I mean you know
whatever I'll reserve the possibility
that you know we don't know enough about
the universe maybe one day you'll see
you like some dudes with like skulls
foreheads and swords or something and
you know yep we're gonna see the next
viral like stupid person oh yeah running
around on a fake horse you know the
blow-up horse oh wait a minute okay
Arnold
oh my many horses Arnold's way too cool
for that so I was trying to help so the
governador was like was he like a hot
tub or something weren't appengine
aiders the governador that's what we
call him the governor and then the
little horse came up and like cool got
to see that videos you gotta see it it's
pretty funny thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you